le projet de centre éducatif fermé dans
le château de chardonnay n'est pas assez
pertinents voilà ce qui ressort d'une
réunion organisée au ministère de la
justice entre les élus et l'association
porteuse du projet depuis le début les
habitants s'y était opposé et le maire a
toujours regretté le manque de
concertation
ça a été fait dans en dépit du bon sens
c'est à dire que sans consultation on a
voulu installer ce cfa chardonnay et
c'est seulement après après que nous
avons appris par lorsque la vente s'est
faite il faut désormais trouver un plan
b et le délai est court
un mois seulement créer un nouveau
centre éducatif fermé est indispensable
pour remplacer celui de franny sur la
commune d'autant fermé depuis six mois
la députée cécile inter mayer a donc
envoyé une lettre au maire de sa
circonscription pour trouver un nouveau
bâtiment des retours sont positifs je
constate que les préventions ne sont pas
au rendez vous comme je pouvait le
redouter
mais il faut trouver peut-être le lieu
le plus approprié pour que cette
association qui fait un travail
remarquable la sauvegarde 71 qui ne doit
pas être mise en cause est bien puisse
continuer son office mais dans un lieu
pertinent
la plupart des habitants de chardonnay
espère maintenant que le château de
leurs communes servent pour le tourisme
l'association souhaiterait que ce
château en accord avec la commune le
département et cetera soit en rapport
avec le nos logis
le
comment sur le logis sur un musée du
zinc
quant aux centres éducatifs fermés il y
en aura forcément sur le département
si les élus ne sont pas d'accord le
ministère de la justice tranchera